- You leave the stadium; you
want to see the next game.
You can't wait for the next game.
That's what football should be.
The life is so quick, but
it keeps you in the race.
It's your experience and experience
is what you, what you've done in the past.
Tactical things are so important;
you cannot win without tactical things,
but, um, the, the, the
emotion make the difference.
(loud flipping)
- He's a former
professional football player
and is the current manager of Liverpool.
He spent most of his
15-year playing career
for one team and then became
their longest-serving manager.
He's won the German Football
Manager of the Year twice.
He's Jurgen Klopp, and here's my take
on his Top 10 Rules to Success.
Rule number nine is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best.
Also, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave down in the comments below,
put quotes around it, so other people
can be inspired by your sharing,
and also, when you write it down,
you're much more likely to lock it in
for yourself, too; enjoy.
(thunder)
(bouncing)
(upbeat music)
- For sure, we have only this one life
and we should make the best of it.
That's what I try to.
Best, to do the best
is not to enjoy each
day as, as it, the last.
Or celebrating, drinking, whatever
because tomorrow it could be the end.
No, no, no, it's to, to
make it a better place,
but I think it's only
possible in your surrounding.
Come in a room, try that
the people don't feel
worse when you come in.
So, that's what I try to do,
that's how I under, understand life.
- How would you describe
your footballing philosophy?
- Lively (chuckles).
- Mmm.
I think it's, it's not
the smartest way, I know.
But when it's said, and no, it, I know.
- Success is the smartest.
- But at the end that's how
it is; yes, success for, is cool too.
But first of all, having
memorable games, in a row,
that's my first target.
That the people really
want to see the next game.
You leave the stadium; you
You can't wait for the next game.
That's what football should be
and if you can do this very often,
then you will be successful 100%.
If you always live in the future
and, and hope that something
will change in the future,
you forget that you have to change a lot.
If you always live in the past,
it's a (sighs), maybe for old people,
hopefully, it's, it's nice, ah,
it's nice to think about
wonderful moments and things like this,
but we are not in this, in, in this
phase in our life, we
are in the, in the middle
of, of our life and, a,
a, we have the biggest
influence on everything
and so we should try to, to, to
do what we can to, to make it better.
If not for us, then for our families
or for our friends or whatever,
and that's, that's what we try with.
I think being 100% in the moment
is the only possibility to
get better in the future.
We are not on the world to do,
to do every, do what everybody wants.
We have to, to be a group.
Sometime it's only family,
sometimes it's with friends,
sometimes it's together, and how I
understand it, LFC is family and friends.
Football becomes the game it is today
because you work together
and in this moment, we have,
don't only have 11 players,
who should work together.
Not only 20 players, not 24 players.
We have to work together
here in Melwood, with
all the people working
and with all the supporters in Liverpool,
with all the supporters around the world.
That's what I, what I believe in,
and if you do this,
if we are strong in this,
we will be succeed for sure,
we will succeed for sure.
I had bigger interests
in my life, of course.
In my own career as a player
and in my coach career or manager career.
Yes, it, hard times (chuckles) and mine's
to stay in Bonus League.
I'm mindful of the same challenge
it's, you, you lose I
think 60% of the games,
but you have the chance
to stay in the league
and so you have to learn to handle,
um, these, these things and
that's what I learned, of course.
Of course it was always hard work here
and from the first day
on, but of, of course
it's not the biggest challenge,
but it's the most strange situation
because, ah, usually in football you all,
you're responsible for
all faults you make.
Yes, that's it, that's really
the true story about football.
But in our situation
we had so many problems
with injured players and,
that, yeah, we had to
work and we had to, to, to
stay confident, to stay self-confident
for the moment when we are
ready to, I don't, to run,
to, to fight in, in our best shape.
And that's what, what we have,
but in this time when we have,
when we had to work,
we had one match,
we have the next match,
every three day we had a match, and,
yes, so, we, when everything
in Chairman's league,
everything in Cup and
lost nearly everything
in, in Bonus League.
It's really strange, it's
really crazy situation,
but we are, we had to learn
to handle it because it was,
it was not the absolute surprise
that we had problems.
We need, we knew this
season were we problematic,
um, but, um, we didn't,
you know, handle this
in this size the problem,
so, we had, we had to learn to handle it.
Now, we are in the, in the situation.
We know we, what we have to do.
The players come back,
they get in better shape, and,
and so that's, that's very important,
but we did only one
step against (mumbles).
It's the only one, now our next challenge
Polywon, then Frankfurt, and so on,
so, no easy game.
Every, is always hard work.
And so, we try to do it.
We really work hard that we can be
as successful as possible immediately.
But success has, ah, maybe
has a different view for it.
I would say this season,
going to Chelsea would
be outstanding success
with all the quality around, and, so
there's one team a little bit more lucky,
big quality, and all that
stuff, no injuries, and
that's Chelsea and they
did a fantastic job so far
and if they do it,
and, and, and can carry on like this,
and they'll be the champions
and they deserve it.
And all the rest is fighting for the rest,
more or less, better or, or worse,
whatever, in different moments
and there's pressure on all of us.
We will see who will go through.
But when you get the
target, it's fantastic.
If you don't get it,
it doesn't mean you, you are,
you are bad, you are not the right person
or whatever or does it mean,
come on, try it again?
That's the thing, when you are convinced
about a consolation, when
you are convinced about
a people, (cheering) and in this moment
you always think about alternatives,
that's what I do always (cheering).
So is there somebody else
who could do it better (cheering)?
If I would know somebody who could
do it better, I would not be here.
Yeah, ask him, so he can do it
and everything will be good.
So, I'm really, I'm really
convinced about (cheering)
the, the, the circumstances,
the consolation,
the basis we have
and that's what we want to use.
How long it will take?
I have no idea,
but everybody should see that we tried
really, everyday, really hard.
(loud flipping)
I don't live in the past,
but I like all our, it's, it's
like with family; father, grandfather,
things like this, so there's always
a reason why you are here.
This is, if you want the grandfather
and father of, of Liverpool, as seen,
they are the reason why we are here.
The life is so quick,
but it keeps you in the race.
It's your experience and experience
is what you, what you've done in the past
and, and so it's,
sometimes you can use the
experience of other people
and that's what we try.
- How would you personally describe
your style of leadership?
- Close to the human being.
I think discipline is very important,
very important, but
discipline is relative,
especially with, when you work
together with young players.
Yeah, never lose the, the target.
I don't know how to say,
never lose the target,
always stay focused on it
and so that's, that's pretty clear
because that's, and always, um, yeah,
think it's still possible, so that's the,
that's not the right words in English.
- Believe.
- But, I would say, yeah,
for sure believe it's, it's, it's
a little bit different to belief.
Belief is, um, you can create,
you can belief in something,
but you can lose belief quite easily.
So to be stronger in a bad
moment, things like this.
I've watched so many matches
in my life, unbelievable.
And I really, not so,
there are some boring games
and then I, I, I sleep.
It's so boring I think,
oh, why they beat each other
and make this 20, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80,000
people in the stadium,
when it's a boring game, it's not okay.
So that's what we, what we want to see.
We want to enjoy our, our own game.
If we lose, okay.
We like to win, but if we lose
with our way, it's okay.
If we lose with the way of somebody else,
it's, it's, you, you
cannot work with this.
So, that's it, it's very emotional,
very fast, very strong,
not boring, no chess, like this.
- No tactical.
- No, yes, of course tactical.
Yes, but tactical with, with big heart
and tactical things are so important.
You cannot win without tactical things,
but, um, the, the, the
emotion make the difference.
Life in our, in our game that's important.
- You're emotional; on
the side of the pitch
I watch you, you're, you know.
- Yeah, but if it's a sizable game,
yeah, that's only one
part of me, to be honest.
It's most of the time I'm, I'm,
I'm not that emotional, thank God.
So, but, during the game,
something happened to me I don't know.
I, I, until to now, 49, I cannot exactly
explain what it is.
But, if I would see another person
doing what I do,
I will think, is he crazy?
(loud crowd)
- Look now it's not just the Cup anymore.
It's the whole ground forces of him.
- Yeah.
- You know, unlike (mumbles)
he want us to stand up
and everyone (mumbles)
he's looking at clock now
and watching the football
because he's peeking and wait
see what he's going to do next.
But he's fantastic, you know.
(thunder)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Fernando Taveres asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what did you learn from this video
that's going to have an
immediate impact on your somehow?
What clip was your favorite?
And what are you going to take
immediate action on now
in your life or your business
after watching this video?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'll join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out to
Kelly Quittenton, Kelly, thank you so much
for picking up 10 copies of my book,
Your One Word, and sending it out
to some of your friends.
I really, really, really appreciate it
and I hope you and them
are enjoying the book as well.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever Your One Word is.
Much love; I'll see you soon.
(thunder)
(bouncing)
- So, let's talk about football,
think about football,
and let's play football.
That's, that's what we try
with all the pressure on it,
with all, with all it's about,
how long it was since
we won the last title.
But if you want, it's
I don't know, 20-something years
or this the first year since we really
try really to win again
(chuckles) something
because we all learned now
from the past, then it's only
one year until now,
so, that, that, that
fits better, actually.
So we decide how it should feel
and if they are patient enough,
I think a lot of good
things can happen here.
And that's what we have to learn.
We have to take the games like they are.
We don't have to, to value or rate
the, the opponent before the game
and say against this it should be easy.
No football game is easy.
So and at the end it's the
question is it possible
to, to create a most special
atmosphere at three o'clock
Saturday afternoon at Enfield?
More special than each and
every game, is it possible?
I would say, yes.
So, let's try it.
And the atmosphere is two com,
two things which is very important
is, is the crowd and it's the team.
So, I can do a lot to
bring us in the right mood,
but I really would love to see
that everybody goes with
the right expectation
in a game like this and it's not
disappointed in it when we,
when we miss a chance in
after 10 minutes and think,
oh God, difficult again;
it should be easier.
Why should it be easier?
When we can win against teams,
which the people think they
are stronger than we are.
Why another team, which the people think
is weaker than we are,
shouldn't have the opportunity to win?
So that's a, that's a real,
it's a process, that's
something we have to,
we have really to learn.
It's, it's, it's, we can always talk about
the same things, we can always say about
against these teams something was wrong
and, I can 100% guarantee it's not about
the attitude of the players, 100%.
It's not that they think,
that's, ah, why should we
put everything in this game, huh, why?
That's not about this.
So, let's try to create really
an atmosphere which
everybody is completely
in, in their performance,
in the game, concentrated,
is happy about creating moments,
happy about creating chances,
missing chances and information not more.
So it's always only that the, the,
that we can show, yes, we know
how we can cause them problems.
And if we stay then concentrated,
patient, but greedy and direct,
yeah, then we will have the next one.
If we, the more you have,
the more likely is it that you use one.
(thunder)